it's been a tough year for premier
esports events
as fans we've been deprived of the cs go
major
the international and the mid-season
invitational
but amidst a global pandemic and the
whirlwind of logistical nightmares that
come with it
we might just get the most exciting
league of legends world championship
ever let me tell you why
all right guys so if you're into esports
news shows like this one
you're gonna love our talk show clouded
every wednesday at 1 pm eastern
me and the guys from the scored esports
get together over on our twitch channel
twitch.tv slash the score esports
to talk about all the biggest headlines
and give you our takes
so make sure you're following and turn
on notifications and we'll see you there
alright let's get back to league of
legends i know it sounds maybe a little
bit too good to be true
after all of the cancellations delays
and rescheduling we've had due to covet
19
but we are actually getting a 2020
league of legends world championship and
let me tell you
i am stoked and not just because it
feels like one of the only
real esports events in months but
because it's actually shaping up to be
one of the most exciting international
tournaments we've seen in league of
legends
in a long time you never know what will
happen
at worlds the stage is set
the curtain is drawn
this is the key people want to see
now before i get into the specifics of
each region let me break down some of
the
overarching storylines first and
foremost the event is going to be 22
teams instead of 24 teams and that's
because vietnam can't make it due to
covid
but it does seem like it's going to be
held in person we know that the players
are traveling to shanghai for the event
we know that the lpl finals in china
were held
in an arena with no fans so even though
riot hasn't told us yet
everyone's assuming that's how worlds is
gonna play out also for the first time
this year the two regions with the most
recent international success china and
europe
will be sending four teams to the event
which
may seem small but is a big deal for
league of legends fans
for a long time fans have complained
that some of the strongest teams get
locked out of worlds because each region
is only allowed to bring a certain
number
so hopefully this helps that problem all
that said maybe the most exciting
global storyline headed into worlds this
year is the lack
of a mid-season invitational for the
first time in the modern era of league
of legends we have
absolutely no idea how these teams stack
up against each other and that's got me
really excited
because anything could happen with that
said we do
have a favorite china yeah it's official
china has overtaken south korea as the
region to beat
in international league of legends that
may not be news to many of you
but this year's world championship is
certainly a changing of the guard for a
lot of people
it's clear that china is the favorite
for this event but they also look like
the deepest region
two characteristics we've used to
describe south korea coming into worlds
for a long time with that in mind
there's also another changing of the
guard
happening within the chinese region
itself at the upper echelon of the
region we've got the favorites for the
event
top esports and jd gaming two orgs you
would not describe
as legacy chinese orgs this year in
china
young teams like jdg and top were able
to come out ahead
of legacy teams like royal and invictus
gaming
who we're used to seeing at the top of
the standings even fun
plus phoenix last year's champions
didn't even make it back
as for who the best team in china is
well that's still up in the air
jdg and top played in both the spring
and summer finals this year
in both very close series and they split
them
so i guess we'll find out who's better
at worlds dracula gets onto lumo who's
incredibly low kenavi falls result
wasn't available and it's going to be
top east boss
winning out the fight top esports
winning
out the series as they take elder and
stun through onto yagao and it's 3-6-9
to finish the fight
the old guard have fallen in a new era
begins in the lpl
after years of denial the second place
was no longer good enough
and top esports are your lpl
2020 champions
now joining those two chinese teams is
the other quote-unquote
really good team at worlds this year
damn one from korea such a great
position
you can see it but it is going to be the
rendezvous oh now the team fight barrel
looking for a pulverized target
carrier is going to go down first oh now
in trouble
there's nothing joby can do
congratulations
to don juan for the first time one of
our teams promoted from the challenges
korea that said similar to those teams
from china
they don't come sporting legacy korean
names with a ton of worlds experience
these guys are young guns there is a
little bit of a question mark though
nuggery has a collapsed lung and we're
gonna have to see how much
practicing he actually gets done with
his team before worlds
between nuggery and their mid laner show
maker damon possessed the kind of
generational solo lane talent
we're used to seeing from korea even
last year when dam 1 underperformed at
worlds
there was a lot of eyes on these two
guys and it's time to show that they can
do it at the highest level
alright let's talk about europe at the
beginning of this year
there was hope hope that somebody could
finally win a split that
wasn't fnatic or g2 some up and coming
team like
rogue or mad lions could put it all
together and finally take down these two
juggernauts
but like clockwork g2 ended up winning
both splits to make it four in a row
and beat fnatic in the finals both times
you can see actually in the bases caps
caps is going in for the win what will
g2 way to close out this game wonder
will kill reckless
yancos goes in and helps them get hilly
and caps is in the base
10 splits eight titles
g2 are the greatest team we have
ever produced in europe and they go back
to back to back to back and win the
summer season
which continues a rather incredible
trend of the 16 total european splits
that have happened
fnatic or g2 have won 15 of them now
with that said i think the big question
on
everybody's mind when it comes to europe
is can g2 compete internationally
like they did last year well this year
g2 certainly don't look
as dominant there were question marks
surrounding their bot lane for a lot of
the summer and caps
certainly had to do a little bit more
carrying from the mid lane
than he maybe would have liked that said
they did prove it last year
they can compete with some of these top
teams and with no msi this year
the rest of the world is not taking g2
lightly and finally
we've got north america the only major
region
not looking to win the tournament
korea's got dam 1 and drx
chyna's got the two favorites for the
tournament and europe's got g2
all contending to actually win the
tournament this year in north america
we've got tsm who by all accounts would
be
thrilling to watch even make it out of
groups after a two-year hiatus tsm are
back at worlds
and they've assembled pretty much all
the firepower
na has to offer in bjergsen and
doublelift but they simply do not stack
up against the competition
doublelift had a lackluster summer split
and compared to some of these chinese
and korean rosters
it's really hard to imagine tsm making a
run at this thing
that said they do have one overwhelming
bright spot
bjergsen by all accounts bjergsen had
just about the most
1v9 split of his entire career this
summer
dardoch working his way back in the
fight biofoss is going to be doing the
same bjergsen over the ball looking to
find the moves power of evil
shut down go for it after two items uh
1v1 here from monster and pearson and
bjergsen dodges every single skill shot
so far hawks landed the ulti and nothing
else
that one's point and click zero way to
live he is truly playing at the top of
his game
and the international scene respects him
he can compete with these guys and he is
going to have to
if tsm even wants to have a chance no
offense to flyquest or liquid but maybe
the other most significant north
american storyline is who's
not going to worlds cloud9 after a
spring split that made them look like
one of the most
dominant north american rosters ever
cloud9
imploded in the summer with blabber down
it is a 2v4 cloud9
started this season looking so damn good
but tsm have risen to the occasion
they have taken down the nexus turrets
they will take down
the remaining players on the cloud 9
roster for the first time in
seven years c9 will not be attending
worlds
and tsm will claim their victory
which as a north american fan is
extremely disappointing
because after that spring split many
people saw
this as the year that cloud9 could have
made a real bracket run at worlds
so there you have it all the regions
from the chinese powerhouses to bjergsen
trying to carry all of
n a on his back specific regions aside
one thing that you're going to want to
take into account while watching worlds
is play styles
in recent years there's been a huge
emphasis on aggressive
skill intensive and risky play at worlds
teams like top esports and jdg
are going to be willing to take those
early 5050s and rely on their high skill
level players to win those close fights
so if g2 or fnatic really want to bring
home a world championship to europe
they're gonna have to find a way to take
it to those chinese rosters
and win those fights themselves
something they obviously weren't able to
do
last year or in 2018. now this style of
play in combination with the fact that
both china
and europe get to bring an extra team to
this year's dance
has people extremely excited for this
tournament
some people are even saying that this
might be the most competitive group
stage we've
ever seen at worlds which gets me hyped
because
well [ __ ] i love a good upset whether
you're a casual league fan
or a die hard this is a tournament that
you do not want to miss
finally in a year where the highest
level of competitive esports
curled up into a ball and disappeared
we're going to have a huge tournament
where
literally anything could happen this
could be
the most exciting world championship in
league of legends
history um and board
and board
[Music]
monkeys